みなさんこんにちは
初めまして浜でいうとと申します
僕はですねと関西学院ティガという大学に入る学生でございまして
m ちー活性化の npo に入っております
皆さんに早速ちょっと質問をしたいんですけどもそれは京都といえばどんなイメージが
ありますか
例えばダウン皆さん中で今思い浮かんだのは多分
興味喘息だったりとかっていう声をて上がったりとか
神社跡ですねこのまま舞妓さんとかこういったイメージをた6京都に対して持っている
方っていうのは非常に多くいらっしゃるんじゃないかなと思います
ただですね今日はを神社でもお寺でもマイクさんでもなくこの海のある京都についての
お話をします
ここ後の海のある京都京都府北部の端度という地域で僕は地域活性化に取り組んでい
ます
じゃあ今日はもう一つ質問させていただきたいと思います
この中で地域活性化にまあ関わっている所へ
興味がある人そんな方はどれ位いらっしゃいますか
ちょいじゃあまったく関わったことがないしてとかあんまり興味ないでしょってどれが
ありますか
半々ぐらいですね
僕の中ではこうは京田辺だったらまあ非常に都会だからあまりこうかかったことか
恐怖であるしないからと思ったんですけど意外どう興味がある方とかやってる方が
いらっしゃってちょっとびっくりしたなと思います今日はですね僕の話を聞いて頂いた
後には何か地域って面白そうだなとかな地域で関わってみたいなとか
だかあわよくば eu でもしたいしたいんだとまたそんな風に思ってもらえたらいい
なと思ってお話をさせていただきたいなと思います
今日する話の中で僕が一番伝えたいのは
人人と地域にはものすごい可能性があるなという話です
そして地域というのは人の可能性を開花するような場所であるというお話をしたいなと
思っております
その前に少し自分の話を少しさせてもらいたいなと思います
僕自身ですね少年時代非常に冴えない少年でございました
勉強を苦手でスポーツも苦手で友達ずゲーム苦手
まあそんな少年でした
10人の野球チームに所属していたんですけども僕だけ試合に出れない
それぐらい会スポーツもできない少年でした
だからこそ僕は何に対しても自信が持てませんでしょ
自分はなにやっても駄目だ何やってうまくいかない
そんなことを思っていた少年時代でした
ただ高校生のときに転機がありましたそれは地域でボランティアを始めたことです
当時僕は地域のイベントで自分で
出し物をしちゃう
地域のイベントのお手伝いをしたいまあそんなことをするボランティアをやっています
その時地域の人達に言われたのはイヤー君は海のに頑張ってるねーとか
いやーこれから決めるにかかってるからねっていうのを地域のおっちゃん方に言われた
んですよ
地域やとは会社がなかなかいいないっていうのは多分どの地域でもそうだと思います
だからこそ値今となれば当たり前にいうことなんだろうなと
まあ思えるんですか当時の僕からしたらわっ
こんな自分でも認めてくれる人たちがいるんだ
こんな自分でも評価してくれる人がいるんだっていうことに
と思えるきっかけになりました
初めて自分を認めてくれた場所が地域だったからこそ
うがそこから自分のフルートに何か恩返しをしたい
この地域のために何ができるようになりたいと思い始めました
そのためには自分自身が強くならないといけないし自分自身がもっと勉強してもっと
色んな知識をつけないといけないと思いましょう
そこから自分はビッグできなかった勉強して大学受験をしたり
大学に入ってからいろんな勉強したりいろんな地域に入って地域活性とはを学んだり
いろんな人達
とあって自分無見識を広げないそんなことをするようになります
それが自分の地域活性化に取り組んだきっかけです
でそこで僕は大学に入り第5回大阪に行ってきました
とかいっていうのは非常に素晴らしいなあと僕は床屋に行きと思いました
それは何かというと刺激的な人がたくさんいるなっていうのが僕の都会に来たときの
感想です
同世代にもかかわらず自分で会社を立ち上げているような所がいたりとか
たですね今日もペットで競ったと思うんですけれども
どうせでこう研究を頑張ってものすごい自分とは違うところことを取り組んでいる所が
痛いとか
あとはスポーツだったりとか芸術性何が一つ
成し遂げようとしている人達まぁそういった所がたくさん都会にはいるなと思いました
そしてそういった人と触れ合うともっと子
今日も頑張りたいなもっと自分も何かしていきたいというふうには思うようなきっかけ
にもなりました
ただ一方でそういった育ちだけがいるわけでもないなと思います
とか言ってまだ思ったのは何かしたいけど
をどうしていいか分からないなとかなんかなにかしていいけどモヤモヤしまーそんな所
が痛いとか
何かこう競争さでしょ競争社会にも破れてこーいこー自信を無くしてる人だったりとか
活力が失われている人だったりとかまあそんな人たちも見てますよまあ少し言い方が
悪いかもしれないですけど
まさしく吸っている人か
でついて菅後回にもたくさんいいなと思います
そこで僕は思いました
活躍する場所は必ずしも都会だけじゃなくていいんじゃないかと
地域に行けばもっと活躍できる場所いっぱいあるのにと僕は思います
地域というのは少しいろんな人からこう離れて見られている橋かもしれませんが僕に
とってはものすごいチャンスがある場所だと思っています
それはなぜかというとその人口減少っていう現象がすべてをかばっていると思います
少し説明させてもらいます
今人口減少をしているというらー皆さんご存知だと思うんですけれども
2040年までですね896の自治体が消滅するとも言われています
この人口減少が進んでいくことによってどんなことが起きるかというとまあたくさんの
課題がその地域の中で起こっていきます
例えば僕今6個あげているわけですけどもこれ以上にもたくさん
地
家に課題が生まれてきます
これらの課題というのは
悲観的にとらえるとあたくさん課題が生まれてきてこの地域って思ってなんかやらない
といけないと大変だなと思えるかもしれません
ただこのポジティブに考えてみましょうするとこれらの課題っていうのはものすごい
チャンスなんじゃないかなと思っています
でなぜこれがチャンスなのかというとですね
まず一つ
課題がたくさんあるけれども人がいないんです地域っていう
つまりですかバエが転がっているときにそれを解決しようとまぁ取り組むことができる
時に自分がやりたいですとてあげたらそれをやらせてもらえる
まぁコレだ一つ地域のいいところかなと思っています
もう一つは有休取材がたくさん余っている
これこれは空き家だったりとか廃校だったりとかもそうなんだと思うんですけれども
何かやろうと思ったときに使えるリソースがたくさんあるのが地域のいいところだと
思います
そして3つ目は人口減少という課題が世界最先端の課題であるということです
地域って一見地味で目立ってないかもしれませんが
人口減少して言ってるっていうのは日本が最先端です
じゃあその課題に取り組むことができるということが一つ
チャンスなんじゃないかなと思っています
そういったチャンスが
地方にはたくさんあります
だったら都会で活動すると界で活躍するだけが全てなんじゃないかな
すべてではないと思っ
都会で活躍してないが成し遂げるというのは非常に僕は素晴らしいと思っています
そしてそれもいいがあることだと思っていますただみんながそうじゃなくても
この地地域でないが取り組む地域でなに行くことを成し遂げる
そんな所が増えてきてもいいんじゃないかなと思っています
ということを踏まえると少しは地域に対するイメージとか考えが少し変わった方も
いらっしゃるかなと思います
がじゃあとはいえ今から移住しようと眼科行ってもすぐに薬を移住とかはできないなと
思っています
家いきなり重賞と覚えないと思います
なので僕がここで提案したいのがこの関係人口という関わり方です
この中で関係人口という言葉を聞いたこともある人もいれば
また聞いたことがないしパパでもいらっしゃると思うので少し紹介させていただきたい
なと思うんですけども
この関係人口というのはですね
その町に住んでいる定住人口
なーんーまぁ10人の人口ではなくまたまた
その観光客だったりとか全くその地域に関わりのない
交流人口という人たちでもない
その間の人口のことを関係人口と言います
ああああああ
何言ってるかわからないぞと思っている方もいるのでもう少し具体的に説明させて
いただきます
例えばこの同社大学を起点に考えてみられると言いたかっています
この同志社大学があるのは京田辺市ですよね京田辺市に住んでいる人っていうのはこの
定住人口にあたる書だと思います
ああああああ
まったくこの京田辺市に関係がなかったりとか起きたこともないでしょ
観光行ってきたことあるようライナスは a
この関係ない交流人口かなと思います
例えば大阪市に住んでたりとか京都市に住んでるけどもこの
同社大学に通ってる人達っていうのはまあ関係人口であるかなと言えます
まだと通勤や通学で関わっている人たちだけを人たちだけを
まあ関係人口っていうのではなくたとえば
行田辺市にふるさと納税をしてるでしょこれも関係人口とよると思いますまた今東京に
住んでるけども実家今日たるみにあって
毎年お祭りのために帰ってくるとか松江市帰ってきているそういったしてもまあ関係
人口と言えるんじゃないかなと思っています
そんな関係人口を作る取り組みを北 a ま
京都の丹後で行っています
なぜこんな取り組みをしているのかというと僕自身が就職活動をしていた時の話ですが
あります
僕は昨年就職活動をしていました
僕の中では2つな思いがありました
自分の地元に帰って自分で事業を作っていきたいっていう思いが一つ
もう一つは東京に行って it とかそういったことを勉強して地元に帰りたい
まあ沿った多いが2つありました
ただその二つを両立できる選択肢はなかなかないなっておくことにぶち当たりました
そして周りの就職活動をしている地元の友達も話を聞きました
するとみんなは地元は好きだけどやっぱ東京で就職するといいます
彼らの話を聞いてるとやっぱり地元には選択肢がない
自分のやりたいことができる仕事がないそんなことを
ていました
だからこそそこで見えてきたのは地元を離れるっていうことは地元が嫌いだから離れ
てるんでなくそのライフスタイルの変化だったりとか
いまう選択肢がないから地元を離れてるんだということに気づきました
そこで僕が考えたのはどんなライフスタイルでもどんなところに住んでてもなにかしら
の形で地元に関われる仕組みだったりとか
プログラムがそういったものがあればいいなともういい
自分はそういった取り組みを始めようと思っていま
行っています
例えばどんな例があるのかというのを少し2つほど紹介させて頂きたいと思っています
一つは我々の npo の栄誉賞話です
僕たちの npo はですね東京に在住する
丹後地域出身者が立ち上げた npo でございます
でこちらの写真はですね3年前ほど前に始めたん
日本三景天橋立でビーチバーを行うという取り組みです
このプロジェクトはですね
地元出身の東京で広告代理店で働く所が立ち上げたプロジェクトです
この浜辺を使ってビーチ場所塗装地元の書及びかけて作りました
東京にいながら某毎月毎週のように地元に通い
地元の手術を打ち合わせをし地元の反対を押し切って完成させたのがこのイベントに
なります
このイベントがうまくいったの僕大きく二つの要因があるなと思います
一つは地元出身の者だけでつくる地元在住者だけで行ったので焼く
地元を知っている外の書がやったからじゃないかなと思います
地元を離れた目線で地域を見たからこそこのビーチバーというのは生まれたと思います
ana の発想でというものは観光地であって多くの観光客が来てくれる場所です
しかし地元の人から見ればいつもあるビーチなんです
ただそれを東京に出た地元出身者がいやこのビーチャー素晴らしくて価値があるんだと
いう発信をしたから
このアイディアが思いついたんじゃないかと
もう一つは白山社が地元出身者だったということがあります
地元出身者だから地域のた家と土地を巻き込んでこのプロジェクトを作り上げたって
いう要因があると思います
これが一つ事例として挙げます
この事例を話してて僕自身も持っているんですか
このように自分で何かテーマを作っテーマを設定して地域との関わり方を自分で
作り出していく
まあそういったた方たちは非常に難しいなと僕は思っています
このように何かを作り出すだけじゃなくてそうじゃない育つでももっと気軽に地域に
関われるようになる必要があるかなと思っています
そこでいま僕が始めているのは地域の会社のお困りが当地域に関心のある食に解決して
もらう
まあそんな仕組みを作っています
例えば今やってるのはこういったことをやっています
京都府舞鶴市にある会社のですね
ブランド戦略会社のブランド戦略というのを
作るのお手伝いしてくださいっていうのを
募集してえっ都市部の人にやってもらうというようなことをやっています
実際にここには地元出身で高校卒業以来まったく地元にかかってないけどこれを機に
地元に関わって何か地域に恩返しをしていく戻したい
そういった方が参加していただいて今実際にこのプロジェクトが動いています
僕は高校行ったそういった人たちのためにこういった機会をどんどん作っていきたいな
と思っています
まさしくこういった関係人口という形で関わることっていうのはものすごい
可能性のあることだと思っています
いや自分が買って何になるんだよとか自分で何か出来る事あるんだろうかと思って
しまう方もいると思うんですけれども皆さんが関わることで必ず地域は何か処理一方
前進すると思っていますそして地域にはたくさんの課題があります
そしてそれを解決するためにはたくさんの人の知恵あったりとか
アイディアが必要だと思っています
だからこそぜひ皆さん地域に一歩を踏み出して何がチャレンジをしてもらいたいなと
思います
そのチャレンジをすることによっちか地域はながら変わらないと思っています
ここからそういったことを生み出すためにこの関係人口という関わり方は非常に
素晴らしいなと思っています
僕は関係人口という関わり方は非常に曖昧な関係だと思っています
白か黒でもは蹴れませんし0か100でも
わけない
そんな関わり方が関係人口だと思っています
グレーでも50でも僕はいいと思っています
しかしだからこそそこでしか生まれない価値が僕は生まれると思っています
これまで泥
すまないからって言って伺って来なかった人だったりとか
住んでるから関わっているそういったかかり方ではなくて
0も100も関係なくにその間をとっていくとか
まあ白か黒か決めずにかかっていくそういったことで新しいかつだったりとか
可能性が地域に生まれるんじゃないかなと思っています
そしてその可能性を目指すための取り組みをがこれからもやっていきたいなと思います
以上でプレゼンテーションおりますありがとうございました
[拍手]